hello everyone uh thank you to thank you
costas for the nice introduction and uh
thank you to the organizer of this
workshop
and of this semester assignments to give
me the opportunity to present today
yeah today i'm going to talk about
going beyond mid-max optimization
and in particular
taking into account the learning
dynamics in adversary london
and i'm going to focus on two specific
aspects so in the context of gams i'm
going to focus about the implicit bias
of adam for gain training
which is basically the goal is going to
be to go beyond mid max optimization by
considering the
fine-grained dynamics of the optimizers
and then there is going to be a second
part about
going beyond max optimization by
replacing the inner optimization methods
by a sampling
the inner optimization loop sorry by
sampling and it's going to be in the
context of adversary training
so the first part is
inspired by a joint work with sami
archer and wangzi
and it's about the implicit bias of adam
uh for gantry
so
i think if you're here you know what is
what again is
so i won't i won't get into
the details of this uh i trust you
and basically what we care about is that
uh this gun
is a game between two players the
generator and
the discriminator where the
discriminator basically wants to
maximize
this uh
like basically the minus cross entropy
while the generator aims at minimizing
this display and interestingly
yesterday i think
we talked a lot about hidden convex
concave payoff and the interesting point
to notice is that the payoff of gan
is actually hiddenly a convex concave so
if you consider it this payoff as a
payoff of the function of the
discriminator and the distribution of
the generator
it's linear for the generator because
it's just
on the expectation here
and it's concave because the log is
concave unfortunately because uh it's
too high dimensional i mean we cannot
solve this min max even though it's
convex concave in the infinite
dimensional space what we do as always
the solution is to parameterize our
network so we parameterize the
classifier
our discriminator flag
and the generator
and we end up with a
min max problem that is now
unfortunately
is finite dimensional but unfortunately
non-convex and complete
and so
how do we solve this how people have
solved this in practice
basically uh at the beginning at least
they served it the deep learning way so
they just computed the stochastic
gradient for theta
update stata with their favorite
optimizer compute the stochastic
gradient for omega update omega and so
on and repeat
and
the two things i want to the main thing
i want to focus on today is this idea of
like you have to pick an optimizer
and
there is a huge discrepancy between uh
when you use
for instance standard stochastic
gradient descent and when you use other
optimizer search as a
before that maybe just a small uh
parenthesis
uh people use a stochastic grid
intersect but we all know and we have
seen a lot today that it doesn't work if
we take the i mean in general if we take
the simple bilinear game
stochastic and even not stochastic
gradient descent ascent diverge
geometrically
away from the solution
so that's why there is there has been a
huge line of work
uh
of people trying to propose uh new
principled methods for guns in the
context of games so all this works got
inspired from uh
the
way older literature literature than
this so for instance uh costas has a
paper on like optimistic methods for
gans
and
optimism dates from
um
19 i think 60 no uh something like this
80 80 um
and uh extra gradient dates from la
carpe verifice 1979
so yeah but this paper were kind of like
revamping the old methods in the context
of games
but unfortunately
there is a inconvenient truth
which is that at least personally
when i tried to run these experiments on
gans
what i saw is this
significant gap
between stochastic gradient descent
ascent and atom so this is basically the
fid threshold inception distance lower
is better this is what matters here
and
on four different data sets i have tuned
i had tuned the hyper parameters
so the basically learning rates most
most of it
for a stochastic range descent ascent
and adam for the accent and decent
direction
and
i
couldn't like get rid of this huge gap
between the performance of adam and sgda
and that's a problem because when i
tried then to
use the principle method that i proposed
in the past so for instance stochastic
extra gradient when i tried to apply
stochastic extra gradient to game
training what really happened is that i
could improve the sgta but i couldn't
close the gap between the performance of
svga and the performance of adam
in this context of image status what
kind of tuning did you try i was tuning
the the learning rate of like both the
i
like standard gradient clipping and
learning your schedule
so i did try the running schedule i'm
not sure i tried
because in part also it's a common claim
that you have
but that's recently just
okay
i want to disprove it too that's my goal
today
uh but uh so
i agree that like yeah my my goal today
is to try to address this uh practical
gap
and uh to figure out why adam is working
that way
and beyond the anecdotes because it's my
personal uh history i want to show you
like some facts that uh you know are
more like about the community
if you look at the state of the art
uh in image generation from basically
2017 to almost 2020
it was all guns after this it was a
diffusion model so it doesn't work
anymore but if you look at all the sota
gans that has been released all of them
i checked all of them
were using adam as an optimizer
also if you look at all this yes
sorry so
the y-axis is the fid
so the state of the art is always
decreasing as a function of time
and yeah x axis is the time and so there
is the developing gp paper
spectrum normalization began for
instance and some other improvements on
the c410 dataset
so
they use other but
they changed the formulation of the gun
they improved the architecture but in
terms of optimizer it always has been
added that was a quarter training
uh and if you look at
the papers that who proposed
let's say
principal methods such as optimism or
anchoring
like all this paper
when they were trying uh to
do some experiments on sifa
also plugged
adam on top of their techniques
and uh yeah i'm part of this
and so the question i want to answer
today is really like why does adam what
does sorry what not why what does adam
do that sgd does not
so a very like a quick
basically a reminder of what adam is
so basically we have this
update
where we have the step size so we update
theta t by using a a specific vector
with like a step size empty is a
basically a momentum and we have a
coordinate twice from a normalization
that depends on the square value of the
passive gradient
so uh yeah it's what's called an
adaptive method and there is a many
justification to explain why it works
well in practice practice
but
this is um
not what i want to focus on
because all these explanations are in
the context of minimization and what i
want to deal with is the context of min
max
moreover in the context of minimization
as mentioned a bit earlier there is some
work that are trying to argue that
adam can be replaced
for instance in the context of image
classification there is this very nice
oral presentation from eurips 2017
that uh basically detail how um a
well-tuned sgd can outperform adam
and there is a yeah the best paper award
that i clear 2018 that basically showed
that there was a mistake in the
convergence proof of atom so we if we
want to use principal methods we may not
want to use adam on top of it because
then we break all the convergence
so yeah so what we're going to like uh
to do is to try to deconstruct adam
in order to figure out what what it has
what it does uh
what what is the specific thing it does
during the training
so basically
it's just an update vector that has a
direction and the norm that differs from
nothing nothing crazy here
but so the crazy thing we tried is to
try to disentangle the effect of the
direction and the effect of the norm in
the training so we proposed two methods
uh what that we call other layer and
adagio
which basically
corresponds to uh
one one of the optimizer use the norm of
the adam optimizer you compute in
parallel the svd
optim update and the adam update and for
one you use the norm of adam and the
direction of sgd so you take your sgd
update and you divide by its norm and
multiply by the number of adam and you
do the same for the other player
and conversely add idea you take the
direction of adam and you multiply by
the norm of sgd so now
what we have is like two methods one
follow the norm of adam and the other
one sorry follow the direction of adam
and the other one follow the direction
of
and experimentally that's
pretty
interesting
what we get is that the one
that
doesn't follow the direction of adam so
it follows the direction of sgd but
has the same norm as adam
is matching almost perfectly and like i
mean with an error bar outperforming
adam
so basically what it says is like what
we only care about the first takeover
from this experiment is that
it seems that it's only the norm of the
adam vector of the adam update that
helps in performance
the second thing we noticed
experimentally is that actually the norm
of this vector was constant across a
so if we summarize this the method that
was working almost as well as adam was
this one
with the direction of sgd that was
normalized and the number of adam but if
the norm of adam is constant we end up
with this like very simple like
optimizer that is basically normalizes
it and so our now like our hypothesis
is that
this optimizer should work as well as
adam and this is like just normalizes it
so this is the thing we tried
we tried basically we took the previous
block that was a bit unfortunate
and we added uh now some just like
layer wise normalized svga and normal is
a cd where we normalize across all the
all the parameters sorry and what we get
is we are able within the robot to match
the performance of adam by just using
this like
mini batch normalization steps
so the conclusion experimentally
is that a normal sdg is a proxy of for
adam or actually i prefer the adam is a
proxy for normalized sgd and this can be
a explanation of why it works
well uh
for guns yes so your experiment is for
gda right yes
you can we can do the same thing for
regular devices
do we have the same behavior that's like
l r what was the name of the two uh and
uh nominees uh
is it still better in the regular
minimization
so that's a good question we haven't
tried the
minimization but in minimization you can
already outperform adam with sgt
so uh
algorithms sorry but between the twelve
columns that you have
um
also something to notice that i don't
talk about in the talk is uh in the
context of gans people use adam with
some specific hyper parameters that are
different from the one in minimization
in particular they put no momentum
and change a bit the beta2 that is
probably changing the behavior of adam
so i don't think and i think that's the
point of this talk i think adam in the
context of gans does something very
different than what what it does in the
context of the standard organization so
that just be sure
in mid marketing
they are or they are not having a
mobile message
parameters
that you know arise out of your
hyperparameter tuning
do you see any negative momentum post
momentum like and the step size
are different
uh yes so um
so for adam uh it's like zero momentum
that is most of the time like uh
the best at the rest
and uh it's
always like a two-time scale uh step
size so different step size for the
generator
i don't remember exactly which one is
larger
and i think for now is the gt you need
i'm gonna say a mistake i think maybe no
no
i don't remember if it's larger but it's
different from uh your step size has to
be different basically it makes sense
from this slide because
uh this this guy is just like plugged
into the step size so the step size of
adam is uh
when you tune is very different from the
step size of what you normalize is
probably a larger you you should get
larger step size for normal as you do
but i'm not 100 sure
so yeah as an experimental conclusion we
have that adam is a proxy for normalized
sgd and okay why is it so great
first of all i'm very happy because uh
it's way much more principle
and why is it was it
why why why do we care because now we
can try to analyze and understand
what normalizes it does in the context
of gans what is its implicit bias
and it's also way easier to tune and
there is the room for improvement now if
we have like extra gradient it's way
easier to try to analyze normalize extra
gradient than to try to analyze extra
atom or optimistic uh
so yeah i feel like it kind of
okay it kind of uh opens the room for a
lot of like analysis and understanding
and so what we did is a
preliminary analysis of the comparison
of normalizes the sdga versus sdd
in the context of a
gun that is
already quite challenging so we have a
linear generator
where basically what you want to learn
is the weight
vi
and so zi are sample or binary latent
variables
that are basically sparse non-negative
and non-positively correlated so it is
this is basically like what is
summarized here
and you want to learn basically the
weights here and the distribution that
is the target is just a mixture of two
mods u1 and u2 that are positively
correlated and basically your
distribution is either
you can get your random variable is
either you and
the realization sorry of your random
variable or either u1 or you so
basically what you would like to learn
with vi is these two vector u1 and u2
and you would like to learn the right
weights
uh so for basically that depends on
these two random variables one s
interestingly there is this work by
allen sue and lee that argues that this
zi that are sparse non-negative and
non-positively correlated can be seen as
the distribution of
the hidden layers of
deeper knowledge so this is what they
kind of show in the the analysis that
this is how like uh basically uh deeper
hidden layers behave
i think i think they proved like some
like
in this vein
this is like a sparse coating
and basically yeah so the the zi or like
like
sparsely yeah but yeah
i mean
it's basically like uh they are sparse
uh most of the time you have only one zi
but you cannot like very unlikely to the
eyes
and so what we have in order to make it
interesting is a two-l2 leonardo nets
with basically a cubic non-linear
so it's cubic around zero and then it's
gonna be linear at some point just to
deal with the the
the deepestness we don't want the
viciousness of the discriminator to go
to christianity
but yeah it's it's roughly a cubic uh
discriminator and we want to basically
study the mean max this linear subject
and the two results
we were able to show are the the
following
so basically the first result
is that
for sdga for any step size choice that
is constant as you just refer from like
mod collapse
uh precisely that like we can only learn
the direction uh u1 plus q2 so you're
never able to learn uh with your
generator with the the weights v vi
uh
either u1 or u2 you're only able to
learn the sum which is like uh i mean
the the average of the mean of the
distribution in some sense something
proportional to the mean of the
distribution this is kind of the
statement that is like um a bit more
detail
and this is with like high probability
but yeah the spirit of the the statement
is that we are not able to learn the
right
uh the basically if we look at uh what
like some illustration what happens is
like
the
discriminator in any cases because of
the cubic non-linearities is learning
this direction the direction of u1 plus
u2 and once like the weights of the
generator
start to catch up it's too late and they
are only
they only basically
get the direction you want pursued so
here is like u1
here is u2
um in green this is the decision
boundary of the discriminator and
something you notice in guns is that the
generator only gets signal from the
discriminator so the only signal that
this data points will get is uh comes
from the decision boundary of the
discriminator and so if the decision
boundary of the discriminator has
converged uh to something that is linear
and
directed by you one question two you
cannot learn anything and that's kind of
the spirit like the spirit of the proof
on the other side
if you
have picked the correct choice for
normalized sgdl you will learn the
direction of
both modes so with the right with enough
iteration and enough steps i mean the
right step size tuning
what we are able to prove is that the
generator is able to learn the direction
of both mode
meaning that like there is a
non-vanishing probability
that
basically we are
close we are we are close there is a
non-vanishing mass of the generated
distribution that is close to to u1
and youtube
so the remarks here is like
this is proven in a very specific
setting that doesn't is not as general
as general as
you know non-convex non-concave gans and
any architecture it's for a specific
choice of generator and discriminator
and it's certainly about
the direction so one very weakness of
our analysis is that we are not able to
learn
the correct
u i but we are able to only learn the
correct direction so we need to
normalize to get the result
also we have no guarantees that
normalize sgd learns the correct
weighting meaning that we have no
guarantees that this probability is
actually equals to the correct
uh
the correct points so like because the
target distribution is a mixture of u1
and u2 and there is no guarantee we
recover the correct mixture coefficients
so the illustration is the following so
because of the normalization of the
gradient
the generator is able to basically learn
very quickly something and
what ends up happening in this like uh
experiment uh is that as we can see some
of the math goes uh on one mode and some
of them as goes on the other one of
course our theory cannot uh i mean we
don't prove that all the math is like on
both modes but at least we get a
non-zero one on each of them
so the conclusion of the first part is
that
gans
has some uh in some sense very bad
approximate stationary point and local
equilibrium
and uh it seems that like normalized
gradient could be one of the key for
training gans and
adam in some sense was used as a proxy
for normalizes normalized grid
normalized sgd
and so in some sense if we want to study
minimax optimization and particular
convergence
in the context of learning sometimes
convergence guarantees are not enough
because we have this like very bad uh
like stationary point
and and so we need to consider the
dynamics of uh our optimizer in
particular like
what is called like what i call here and
like what people like to call implicit
biases of each learning algorithm is
important but in that specific setting
it's really about understanding the fine
grain
uh
having a fine grade understanding of the
dynamics really like figuring out in the
context of gans
what is going on and why why normalized
gradient does something that
sgda doesn't
so in some sense yeah and if we want to
do this of course like general
non-convex and concave minimax
optimization is uh two general
so like the question that remains uh
open i mean of course
we all our analysis is in the case of
batch of size one
but more interestingly can we extend
this result to like more complex
generator and discriminator and
understand
uh this
like
in the general setting of guns
maybe we could get have a stronger
result in that case where we don't only
learn the directions
and can we extend this idea to other
like multi-agent settings
sorry about that
uh such as a multi-multi-agent uh
front central smartline
okay so that concludes the first part of
my talk
and uh now i have i think 15 minutes
for the second part
which is exactly what i need
to talk about
like basically a distribution or a
business perspective on adversaries
training
uh
where i basically want to go a bit
beyond this like min max optimization by
replacing the max inner optimization by
some something
so in that work we are in the context of
adversary examples
so uh very quickly what is universal
example there is this very nice and uh
quote by alexander madrid
that says
that machine learning is amazing it's a
wonderful technology because it can
makes
big flights pigs fly
and how do you do this
you take a picture of pig
you take your favorite classifier that
classifies this picture as a pig you you
add this unperceptible transformation
that depends on the classifier that is
called adversary examples and you get
these new pictures classified
with a 99 accuracy as a airline
now uh our goal uh and this is work and
in like uh basically
the robustness literature is to have
microbes classifier meaning that we
don't want to have flying pigs
so we want to train basically a model
that will be robust against this
perturbation and one of the main ideas
one of the ideas to do this is to do
what is called adversarial training
meaning that you train your model
against this adversarial examples and so
the point
i want to make
today is okay but when we look at this
in our maximization
what we do is like we look at the x
tilde that doesn't come from the data
distribution anymore
so in some sense what the classifier
sees is a new distribution that is a
perturbed version of the data
distribution
and so
the way we we may want to reformulate
this maximization
is by a maximization respect to the
distribution
and the question here
is like what is the p
that we should set in order to have this
equality between these two
to basically have the adversary training
from which
so for a general p this is called like
distributional robustness and i think
we're going to have very nice talk about
this right after me
it's it's a very old field that starts
uh before 2000
and uh that uh there is some people that
recently draw connections with adversary
examples i'm not the first one to notice
that
we can have
basically there is a connection between
these two formulations
yes
just to be sure that they understand
it's the first time that they see that
you claim that you i have an integral
this is what i see i have an integral
they have a
maximum operator over a function
i can put out the maximum operator if
you put the right constraint here i see
and
the p would be a convex
in that case it will
okay
yes
that's the whole point actually the p i
can do the spoiler there the spoiler p
is
the basserstein ball
it's like the infinite versatile mode
of size epsilon around the data
description centered at the data
research interesting
but it's a very good question because
the next slide is giving you the details
about this
uh so the novelty here is uh really
trying to figure out what is the right p
so really making this tight connection
about when like what is the p to get
this equality
and uh basically what we figure out is
that there is a connection between
optimal transport and the infinite
infinite the sustainable constraint
so in some sense you can see x
tilde as the result of a transportation
of x
uh by following this constraint epsilon
and so in some sense what you
the p adds the intuition is that it
shouldn't be transported
yeah more than epsilon respect to a
certain matrix
so yeah so the way we prove this is like
if you if we don't we want to transport
x tilde not too far from x so we want a
transportation map that transports the
data distribution to the adversary
distribution
with the constraint that basically
so we have this like transportation map
that says
who is transported to who and
what we want as a constraint in order to
to satisfy the blue the blue constraint
is that the support
is only constituted constituted of
the y's here that are the same and x and
x tilde that are smaller than epsilon
with respect to this l-infinity node
so once we have this uh we can realize
that actually this exactly correspond to
what is called the infinite infinite
versus standard distance so it's
basically
the infinite vessel stand distance with
respect to the l infinity node
and what we got at the end is this very
nice equality between
adversarial robustness sorry other side
training
and basically distributional robustness
with respect to this ball
okay but why to why do we want to do
this
because now we we have this perspective
that the adversary distribution is just
the result of a transportation of the
original data distribution
and optimal transport has some very nice
tools and tricks we've got to adversely
self-transport and in particular
something very convenient often is to
use the entropic regularizer in order to
when you do transport between two
distributions and so if we do this if we
add an entropic regularizer to our
original problem
now we get a class form solution for the
optimal
adversary distribution so basically when
we solve this maximization
with an entropic eraser we get
we get a class form that is basically
this one
what it says roughly
is that uh
the
density at a adversarial example is
proportional to exponential lambda
the value of those so the higher the
value of the loss is the more likely the
adversary
the the higher the density of the
adversarial distribution is at
so it makes it make sense
the problem is of course it's it's
harder to compute uh
this this uh the normal is the
normalization of this density but we can
basically simulate this uh distribution
using a laundry monte carlo sampling and
so what we do now because we have this
class form for the inner maximization
problem is to replace optimization
that was trying to solve the in our
maximization problem by a sampling step
where we will try to sample this
adversary solution
and
why is it is it important and reverend
because it leads to a
very natural and practical
implementation of adversarial training
that
consists on some slight modification of
the previous methods
so basically now because we want to
sample from a distribution we need to
maintain this distribution so we kind of
have this this perspective tells us that
we should memorize
the adversary examples that correspond
to each data point in between the step
and and keep them in memory as the
current adversarial distribution so this
is what you you have here you initialize
basically your adversary examples
and um at each time step you load
your like memory of the other side
examples
you compute your gradient or the sign of
the gradient
in this case to update
to to basically update your adversary
examples and you use largemouth so you
follow the the gradient and add some
question noise in order to kind of
sample from this uh distribution
and then once you have this you do your
gradient distance step that are the
standard updates of the model against
what is the adversary data set and you
save what is very important the attacks
so the novelty here is that instead of
each time step you recompute the
adversary example against your model you
have this like adversary distribution
that you slightly update as you learn
your model
and the key insight is that because we
had like used this entropic
regularization
we we have that the function the
adversary distribution is continuous uh
it's a continuous function of the model
parameters so as our model trains our
adversary distribution slightly changes
and so we can do this alternated steps
in order to update each other and we
save a lot of a lot of time because now
we only need one or two inner steps of
learning instead of like 20 or 30 in
practice
to update our adversary examples
so i mean all this wouldn't be
interesting if it doesn't work in
practice so fingers are crossed
we have the first
experiments that are mnist
so y-axis is the i think the
adversary error rate
uh yes yes it's so error rate is a
adversarial test error versus pgd14 so
on the test set we compute adjacent
examples and we look at the robustness
of the classifier so lower is better
and so what we see is that
of course because we do last step of the
inner problem it takes a bit of time to
take off
for the learning of the
the model but at the end of the day this
is faster than pgd140 but what i didn't
take into account here because here the
number of epochs is the fact that each
step
is
significantly shorter because i only do
one or two grading steps for the
launcher instead of 20 of us so if i
look actually at the time comparison
what i get is a like basically
x 30 faster improvement because each
inner step is like basically one
gradient step instead of 50.
and so at the end of the day i we get a
significant improvement in terms of
performance
and this uh scales up uh also to see if
i will get like 10 times faster
improvement to get the
the performance of the
standard training against pgd14
and uh yes
sorry the y-axis is the adversarial
test error against a pgd14
pg projected gradient descent gradient
ascent sorry important so does it change
if you use for example pgb200
200 i never use this
yeah of course not for training uh
that's a good point uh
changes the the behavior so for
evaluation it is better to use at least
hundreds
okay so this is nothing i think we can
definitely do it
um
so what i can tell you is we were doing
uh as the fast
sign gradient method before and it was
even
more in our favor the results
so i we will try your pgz1
but ok
so the conclusion
for the part 2 is that
we have provided this distributional
business on
training by like tightly by defining
what is the right distributional
robustness constraint in order to
formulate it as a
to formulate adversary as distributional
business
uh with the
categorization we got a class formed
for the
basically
this min max problem for the inner
maximization of the minimax problem
that allowed us to replace the inner
maximum optimization by sampling
and basically the two tricks is
basically now we have to maintain a
adversary a data set that kind of warm
start the sampling
because this adversarial data set is a
continuous function of the classifier
and we got a huge speed of speed up of
course there is two main caveats to this
method
first we need to keep a adversarial
dataset in memory so we need to maintain
it so it's more expensive
but at least in the case
in the case of sifa and amnesty it's
it's not a problem and even in the case
of imagenet uh we are like working on
some tricks to make it work and it
should
um at least we should have something
that fit in memory i don't know if it's
like you will train well but we should
be able to have
some proxy for the adversary data set
and the second caveat is uh it's a bit
uh it's an interesting one because it
opens a
uh
some questions which is like um it's
hard to deal with data augmentation
because now you cannot maintain a
adverse example for each the augmented
example you don't know i mean you don't
know in the future how your example will
be augmented basically
so you have to
you have to figure out some tricks but i
want to point out that
uh if you look at like the standard uh
other side training methods on sifa it
was trained with no data augmentation it
seems that
using
the preliminary experiment we do seems
to indicate that data augmentation
improved the clean
test error but doesn't improve that much
the
robust the tester on against adversary
examples
so that's it
for me thank you everyone and
i will now welcome your questions
my question is very good here
let's get this
question on the second part um
i think the distribution like taking out
the distribution to washington that is
pretty straightforward but
why do you gain anything using the
entropy regularization because when you
add entropy regularization
before you have a coupling right between
your x and x primes it's a deterministic
coupling
these are your adversarial examples and
clean examples but when you add entropy
regularization
basically no you don't have a one-to-one
mapping right so because you are in
increasing the entropy
to get the closed form so basically one
sample basically one clean sample can
potentially be coupled
to it is adversarial example maybe some
other example
so why do you
what's the intuition that it should help
that's a very good question so at least
i have a theoretical intuition we are
currently investigating
uh you know doing an ablation study
whether or not it works like it really
helps in practice but in theory i think
the the good intuition is really the
fact it's what i put yeah here is the
fact that
now the distribution is continue is a
continuous function of the classifier f
and so while we are training f
the distribution is like slightly
shifting to
uh so for instance
you know if you have an adversarial
example before the regularization what
you have is like a adversary example
could be in a given corner and while
your change function will change
like in a discontinuous way the the the
best adversary example should be in
another part of the space but with the
entropic categorization at the
discontinuity point basically we would
have now a uniform
uh they would be like uh as much
weighted uh in the distribution and so
we're gonna most mostly go from one to
the other to the other
so it kind of allows like not to like to
basically it kind of justify the fact
that if we maintain and warm start
the data set
with the previous list or examples they
should uh the next one should be close
to the previous one so we don't need to
do like a lot of steps
actually we can prove it it's continuous
with respect to a
i think
with the kl we can prove it
so i have one question on this slide so
um
so in the uh
so
from from lines it's hard like too many
symbols but like in line six to
wherever
so where do you do the longer van
so
are you touching every picture no yeah
you are just touching a mini batch
excuse me a mini bar yeah but like
like does that mean that kind of like
you know some some pictures are like in
some older like they have not evolved
enough and
so like is that a problem i agree yeah
so um
i theoretically or practically
practically it's not a problem we know
you know we run the algorithm um
yeah
i the point is
if your mini batch size is large enough
you you you have gone through you don't
do you have gone through the whole data
set uh in not that many uh like
iteration if you if you look at the
experiment for adversarial training i
think this is i think you have a very
relevant point if we were doing only one
or ten passes about the data but in
adversarial training like at least in
the context of mnist and sifa like
amnesty we do 100 epochs
and actually we do uh i i stopped the
the computations but like you you can go
way way further you can go up to like
hundreds of epochs and so it becomes
less um
irrelevant uh because we we really have
like we have passed through all these
store data points like a
large number of times
but that's a very fair point that uh for
instance in like imagenet maybe it won't
work that well because we may not be
able to do like hundreds of epochs
though there is maybe some yeah some
tricks to consider uh
like for instance we could use
um
adversal
there are examples for each like for for
some images that are closed
and like use this one for all the images
so the kind of cluster like the the
represent adverse representative
examples in order to uh make your pass
over it several times during the
training
i mean presumably i uh the same issue so
kind of like the
question you asked about uh
you know incorporating uh
transformations uh related to that right
because kind of like they're
you never see the exact same examples
for instance yeah like you may not see
this exactly so but so what you can do
in that case is like having so there is
a lot of data augmentation
for which you can back propagate through
it so you could have an adversary
example on the image before doing the
transformation
and computing the adversary examples
and adding like the data basically
augmentation has a sort of like new
layer
so there is a trick for this one but i
agree that for very large this data set
it's a bit uh yeah maybe we can try to
kind of cluster the images
but yeah that's working progress to
scale up to uh like
imagine it and even larger datasets
okay
any further questions
all right so
you again wait
uh
when are we starting in 10 minutes
oh i see okay
see you in 10 minutes
thanks again
okay